nueva dieta baja en grasas realmente
ayuda a la gente obesa a perder peso 100
personas obesas elegidas aleatoriamente
son asignadas al grupo 1 y se les pone
en la dieta baja en grasa otras 100
personas obesas elegidas aleatoriamente
son asignadas al grupo 2 y se les pone
una dieta de aproximadamente la misma
cantidad de comida pero no tan baja en
grasa ok entonces el grupo 12 es el
grupo control no le va a tocar dieta al
1 si es para comparar luego tras 4 meses
la pérdida de peso promedio fue de 9.31
libras para el grupo 1 déjame escribir
esto por acá entonces la pérdida de peso
promedio lo voy a escribir así para la
dieta baja en grasa la pérdida de peso
promedio fue igual a 9.31 libras
entonces nuestra media muestral fue 9.31
libras y la desviación estándar muestral
fue de 4.67 estos de aquí son bien
fáciles de encontrar nos los dan
directamente y luego para el grupo
control para el grupo control tenemos
que la media muestral fue 7.40 libras
entonces la media muestral fue 7.40
libras y la desviación estándar muestral
fue igual a 4.04 ahora si vemos muy
superficialmente esta información pues
parece ser que el grupo bajo en grasas y
perdió más peso que el grupo control es
una observación basándose sólo en las
muestras mira vamos a tomar la
diferencia vamos a tomar la diferencia
entre el grupo bajo en grasas y el grupo
control esto de aquí que nos da a ver es
9.31 menos 7.40 ok esto de ahí es igual
a sabes que voy a sacar la calculadora
entonces nos queda 9.30 y 17.4 que es un
1.91 ok entonces es 1.91 la diferencia
de nuestras muestras fue un 1.91 así con
los puros numeritos pues a lo mejor
podríamos decir que las personas que
están en la dieta
realmente pierden un 1.91 más que las
que no lo que queremos hacer en este
vídeo es obtener un intervalo de
confianza de 95% alrededor de este valor
para ver que realmente con un 95% de
probabilidad en la dieta uno se pierde
más que en la dieta 2 o quien sabe a lo
mejor sale que no verdad entonces eso es
lo que haremos abrir sacar un intervalo
de confianza en el siguiente haremos una
comparación de hipótesis con la misma
información ahora para obtener el
intervalo de confianza del 95% tenemos
que pensar en la distribución en la que
estábamos pensando entonces va a quedar
algo así eso sonó raro lo de pensar en
lo que estábamos pensando más bien vamos
a pensar en la distribución de
probabilidad de la diferencia de las
medias muestrales esta distribución va a
tener cierta media pues cierta media
real vamos a llamarle mu de déjame
escribirlo un poco más arriba va a ser
muy
de equis barra menos de barra la
diferencia entre las medias muestrales
pero en vez de ser que son x1 y x2 la
media de x1 barra menos x2 barra luego
esta distribución va a tener cierta
desviación estándar cierta desviación
estándar sigma de de x1 barra menos a
ver es la diferencia de las medias
muestrales entonces es x2 barra verdad
es sigma de x 1 barra menos x 2 barras
ahora lo que queremos hacer es una
inferencia o bueno más bien de encontrar
un intervalo de confianza del 95%
alrededor de nuestra muestra del 1.91 es
decir queremos dar un intervalo
alrededor de 1.91 en el cual confiamos
que el 95% de las veces la verdadera
media va a caer ahí para hacer esto
vamos a voltear la pregunta vamos a
construir el intervalo alrededor de la
media y en vez de construirlo alrededor
del 1.91 entonces la pregunta ahora
sería cómo le hacemos para construir un
intervalo alrededor de la media de tal
forma que con 90
5 % de seguridad cualquier muestra de
esta distribución por ejemplo está con
95% de seguridad cualquier muestra de
esta distribución caiga en esta área de
aquí entonces esta área que estoy
marcando es del 95% 95% entonces cuántas
desviaciones estándar nos tenemos que ir
en cada dirección ajá pues para hacer
esto va a haber una tabla zeta pero
recordemos con 95% en el centro tenemos
que tener 2.5 por acá y 2.5 por ciento
por acá debemos tener 5% repartido
equitativamente en estas dos colas
simétricas ahora cuando veamos la tabla
zeta necesitamos el valor crítico que
queda justo aquí pero hay que tener
cuidado no vamos a buscar 95% porque la
tabla zeta nos da la probabilidad
acumulada hasta ese punto más bien
tenemos que leerla como sigue entonces
la tabla tenemos que interpretarla así
esto de aquí nos va a dar un cierto
valor pero lo que vamos a tener es 2.5
arriba pero si tenemos 2.5 por ciento
arriba entonces tenemos que ver cuánto
tenemos todo
hacia atrás incluyendo la otra cola que
eliminamos entonces tenemos esta área de
aquí que es de 97.5 por ciento muy bien
ahora si podemos encontrar el valor z de
aquí pues va a ser el mismo valor de z
para acá entonces simplemente tenemos
que pensarlo pues en este caso y ahora
sí ya con esto podemos buscar a 97.5 en
la tabla entonces a ver 97.5 está 97 acá
está este de aquí es punto 97 50 o sea
97.5 por ciento esto nos da un valor z
de 1.96 entonces esto es z igual a 1.96
muy bien ahora eso lo que nos dice es
que sólo el 2.5 por ciento de los
resultados o bueno de las muestras de
esta población van a caer arriba de pues
de 1.96 desviaciones estándar a partir
de la media entonces es 1.96 pero 1.96
desviaciones estándar
entonces por sigma de x1 barra menos x2
barra y pues de este lado tenemos menos
1.96 por la misma cosa déjalo pongo más
a la izquierda para que quepa es
simétrico verdad esta distancia es la
misma que esta de acá entonces nos queda
menos 1.96 por la desviación estándar de
la diferencia de las medias muestrales
entonces si hay un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad haber dejarlo escribo por
acá entonces hay un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad 95 por ciento de
probabilidad de de que nuestra muestra
de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales caiga a 1.96 desviaciones de
la media real con numeritos hay un 95
por ciento de probabilidad de que 1.91
caiga
caiga y caiga y me lo voy a poner así me
voy a poner este
esta distancia a esta distancia 1.96 por
sigma de x 1 - x 2 barras o sea la
desviación estándar de esta distribución
de la desviación estándar de este
estadístico bueno otra forma de decirlo
es que hay un que déjame acabar la
oración de arriba 95% de qué 1.91 1.91
es el valor de la muestra desde el
estadístico que obtuvimos este a 1.96
desviaciones estándar de d
la media verdad the moon the moon the x
1/2 x 2 bar o podríamos decirlo al revés
que hay un 95 por ciento de probabilidad
de que la verdadera media mude x 1 - x 2
con barras verdad este
este a 1.96 desviaciones estándar sigma
de x1 barra menos x2 barra de nuestro
valor de 1.91 esto de aquí es
equivalente si yo estoy a tres metros de
ti tú estás a tres metros de mí ok esto
es una distancia es simétrica ahora como
lo hicimos de esta forma va a ser muy
claro cómo construir el intervalo de
confianza para hacer esto simplemente
tenemos que determinar cuánto vale esta
expresión o sea cuánto es esta distancia
de aquí y para determinar esta distancia
basta determinar cuál es la desviación
estándar de esta distribución bueno pues
la desviación estándar de la diferencia
de las muestras va a ser igual a y esto
es algo que estuvimos trabajando en el
vídeo pasado de hecho creo que lo tengo
por aquí abajo y ésta va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada
raíz cuadrada de la varianza de cada una
de esas cosas pesadas con el tamaño de
la muestra ahorita voy a reescribir esto
por acá este por acá arriba va es decir
la varianza va a ser igual a la suma de
las variantes al cuadrado lo escribo por
acá arriba mejor entonces nos queda lo
siguiente nos queda que la varianza es
igual a creo que es mejor si lo vuelvo a
reducir entonces la varianza de la
diferencia de las medias muestrales va a
ser igual a la suma de las varianzas de
cada una de estas distribuciones o sea
esta y esta sigma de x2 barra cuadrada
ahora ya sabemos que la varianza de cada
una de estas está dada por el teorema
del límite central de la siguiente forma
como sigma cuadrada de la población de
x1 dividido entre el tamaño de la
muestra y aquí el tamaño de la muestra
es 100 y luego tenemos que sumar la
varianza de la segunda distribución
muestral está de acá del grupo control
entonces en nuestro grupo control
más sigma de x2 de la población al
cuadrado dividido entre ciento o sea la
varianza entre el tamaño de la muestra
ahora como no sabemos cuánto valen estos
números podemos aproximar los y sobre
todo porque la en es bien grande esto
sigma que son los de la población
podemos aproximar los con nuestras
varianzas muestrales esas varianzas
muestrales nos las dan en el ejercicio
entonces déjame escribirlo por aquí
abajo y esto es igual a ese 1 al
cuadrado o sea la desviación estándar 1
al cuadrado que es la varianza dividido
entre 100 y luego tenemos que sumar lo
mismo con ese 2 o sea la desviación
estándar 2 elevado al cuadrado verdad
esto de aquí es la varianza de la
muestra dividido entre el tamaño de la
muestra ahora estoy aquí nos va a dar la
varianza nos va a dar la varianza para
esta distribución para la distribución
de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales si queremos la desviación
estándar vamos
que saca la raíz cuadrada entonces si
queremos encontrar la desviación
estándar de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales ahorita tenemos la varianza
tenemos que sacar la raíz y se convierte
en la desviación estándar vamos a
calcularlo porque conocemos los valores
aquí nos dicen que ese 13 4.67 4.67 y
que ese 12 4.04 entonces nos queda lo
voy a copiar aquí 4.67 y el de acá es
4.04 muy bien
vamos a tener que elevado al cuadrado
hacer la cuenta y todo eso vamos a sacar
la calculadora y entonces lo ponemos por
aquí nos quedaría la raíz cuadrada de
haberes 4.67 elevado al cuadrado y
dividido entre 100
mas 4.04 elevado al cuadrado y dividido
entre ciento ahí está cerramos el
paréntesis
y pues le damos enter para ver cuánto
nos queda 30.617 10.617 entonces esto de
aquí es igual a es igual a 0.6 17 y pues
regresamos para acá arriba
acabamos de calcular esta desviación
estándar de la distribución y es 0.6 17
muy bien entonces ahora si podemos
encontrar nuestro intervalo porque es la
distancia que necesitábamos una vez que
la multiplicamos por 1.96 entonces
multiplicando ese resultado 1.96 por
punto 61 7 le voy a poner el resultado
nos queda 1 punto 21 02 1.21 pues
entonces este número la distancia que
nos interesa es igual a 1.21 muy bien
entonces hay un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad de que caigamos en el
intervalo determinado por un 1.91 más
menos 1 punto 21 1.91 más menos este
numerito de acá 1.21 muy bien entonces
nuestro intervalo de confianza pues hay
que hacer el extremo izquierdo y el
extremo derecho el extremo izquierdo es
restando los verdad 1.91 menos 1.21
simplemente es punto 7 queda 0.7 y luego
arriba nos queda 1.91 + 1.21 que nos
queda creo que de 2.12 ya sabes que
déjame sacar la calculadora para ver que
no nos estemos equivocando 1.91 más 1.21
a mieres 3.12 que bueno que lo hice en
la cálculo no es 2.2
3.12 deja burro esto nos queda 3.12 muy
bien ahora solo para dejar todo muy
claro o sea no hay exactamente una
probabilidad así este asegura dijimos de
95% de que caigamos en este intervalo
simplemente estamos que simplemente
confiamos en que hay un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad porque pues aquí abajo por
ejemplo no usamos la verdadera varianza
o la verdadera desviación estándar la
estimamos con la desviación estándar de
nuestra muestra así no es una
probabilidad exacta no estamos 95 por
ciento seguros nada más confiamos en que
con 95 por ciento de probabilidad vamos
a caer en ese intervalo de ahí muy bien
esto de aquí es un resultado bien bonito
ahora ya tenemos un 95 por ciento de
confianza por así decirlo de que vamos a
caer en ese valor es decir de que la
diferencia de que la media de estas
diferencias va a caer ahí ahora recuerda
la media de las diferencias y como lo
explico saber la media de las
diferencias es lo mismo que la
diferencia de las medias
entonces pues o sea lo que nos quedaría
es que el valor esperado de la
diferencia de las medias es lo mismo que
la diferencia del valor esperado de las
medias de la población y entonces esto
es un resultado no para la muestra sino
que es un resultado para la verdadera
diferencia de los valores esperados de
las libras que se pierden en cada una de
las dietas en la dieta 1 y en la dieta 2
va con esto en mente parece ser que la
dieta 1 la que es baja en grasas si
funciona de hecho incluso en el extremo
izquierdo de nuestro intervalo de
confianza del 95% se pierde más peso con
esta dieta aquí le dejamos en el
siguiente vídeo haremos una comparación
de hipótesis